six months ago andrew tate decided he
wanted to take over the internet and boy
did he do that as we've watched for six
straight months andrew tatus trended
he's been the most googled man on the
planet and he continues to dominate the
mainstream conversation but in recent
days andrew tate has been taken off
multiple social media platforms and in
some cases not only was he taken off the
platforms himself but some platforms are
actually taking off any content that has
him in it that is insane we tend to live
in a society that talks about actually
encouraging free speech and being
tolerant of views whether we agree with
them or not but it brings in the
question what exactly did andrew tate do
to get kicked off all these platforms
now of course his message is quite
bombastic he delivers it in a rapper
that is somewhat off-putting to some
people but it doesn't mean that he's
wrong nor does it mean that he should be
kicked off of the platform the true test
of free speech is whether you allow
someone else to say something even if
you disagree with them
and so after being kicked off all these
different platforms andrew tate released
his final message he released it on a
website
freetopg.com and in it he speaks for
over one hour about his rise in
popularity what exactly is true and not
true about his history and what he
thinks about deep platforming free
speech and society moving forward the
first thing i took away from this video
is that andrew tate is a master
communicator he understands how to
communicate in the modern age it's quite
compelling to sit and watch someone talk
for over an hour and simply share their
thoughts without much editing and
without anyone there to go ahead and
knock them off their talk track on top
of that there's a number of stories from
andrew's past that he clarifies
including things where people have said
hey he's human trafficking and he says
no i was swatted i don't know what's
true and what's not true but hearing the
other side is important for the public
discourse ultimately andrew tate figured
something out he had a message that was
delivered to millions and millions of
people and obviously a lot of people
were receptive to it there were also
plenty of people who didn't like it part
of popularity in today's world where
people are incentivized to drive clicks
is controversy whether we like that or
not we as a society need to hold up a
mirror and look into it and understand
the platforms incentivize this so we
shouldn't be surprised when someone
figures out how to crack the algorithm
on top of that i saw a number of people
sharing the video saying look i don't
ride with andrew tate but i do ride with
free speech
my prediction is that there's a pendulum
and it's swinging back in favor of free
speech people are getting tired of
de-platforming and censorship regardless
of whether they agree with someone's
ideas or not it's for you to decide what
you agree with and what you don't but we
don't want to live in a world where
somebody sitting in silicon valley can
press a button and erase somebody from
the internet now there will be plenty of
critics that say he's not erased from
the internet he obviously has a website
he has an email newsletter he can do
many other things while that is true
there's still a sense if you get removed
from twitter facebook instagram tick
tock and youtube that's pretty much the
most popular websites in the world and
so my one call to action to each of you
whether you like andrew tate or you
don't whether you agree with his beliefs
or you don't
don't judge someone by six second clips
you see on the internet regardless of
whether it's a celebrity a musician an
athlete a politician or an average
citizen six second clips taken out of
context that never gives you a good
sense for who someone is or what they
think instead try to pursue content that
gives you much more information go ahead
and look for high quality in-depth
conversations understand the nuances of
how someone thinks about a certain topic
or issue and if you want to understand
the difference between the six second
clips and the hyperbole that you've
probably seen on the internet around
someone like andrew tate go watch the
hour-long conversation that he has
directly with the camera my sense is
that you'll walk away and say it's a
completely different person than i
thought i was watching now again it
could be an act or maybe it's not that's
for you to decide
but again we live in a society that
incentivize clicks bombastic claims and
short videos make sure that you don't
fall down the trap because once you turn
over your mental state and your mind to
these platforms they get to program you
make sure that you're intentional about
the content that you consume
go and find the higher intelligence
longer form the more nuanced content
that's where you're gonna learn and
that's where you're gonna get a better
sense for the picture and don't just
fall into some sort of echo chamber make
sure you seek out the other side of
arguments if you believe a go find b if
you believe b then go find a
that's how you'll actually get a better
understanding of these issues and how
you can actually think critically to
form your own opinion society's in a
weird place there's lots of people who
are vying for your attention make sure
that you spend your time as
intelligently as you can
and also take pride in being a critical
thinker thinking for yourself and not
allowing a politician a celebrity or an
algorithm to program how you think hey
you did you like this video great make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time